why study alone when you can study with
a bunch of strangers from all over the
world
this is Gong Fong which translates to
study broadcast in Korean in Japan it's
known as benkyo Doga and in the US and
other parts of the world it's simply
called study with me it's a type of
video in which people prepare for an
exam on camera while other people watch
and study as well this might not sound
like riveting entertainment but these
videos are racking up millions of views
on YouTube so why are they so popular
and is this just the latest example of
lazy content creation or is there
something more going on here why would I
want me on what I thought would be on
great / too difficult a good wait a
minute I chickened won and Chewbacca
super 1 and it came with all it would've
got a mother [ __ ] wait only she seemed
up this youtuber goes by the name the
man sitting next to me he prefers to
remain anonymous
he lives in Korea and is studying to be
a tax accountant he livestreams himself
studying for hours at a time and has
over 20,000 subscribers on his channel
oh you want a chef's kitchen a thumbnail
how do we oh hey don't cut see his
videos show him simply sitting at a desk
taking notes or looking at a book you're
setting for a long time whether it's for
you know high school college or a
professional degree it can be really
lonely and it's always helpful to have
sort of a study buddy this is Jaime she
lives in New York and runs a YouTube
channel called strive to fit
she started her channel when she was in
medical school and continues to foam
herself studying while in residency
unlike the man sitting next to me
Jaime's study with me videos are
pre-recorded her videos range from
around 20 minutes to two and a half
hours in length and some have over two
million views she offers videos with
music and some with the natural sounds
of the pencil on paper as a sort of ASMR
I try to cater to different types of
audiences
it'll just be kind of a natural sign of
life fandom paper or book sounds and ask
with a quick youtube search you can find
all sorts of different people and types
of study videos to choose from this
study video trend is a lot like mukbang
which has become more popular in recent
years it involves people eating food
often a whole lot of it on camera
looking at what's on YouTube these days
like ASMR mukbang and reaction videos it
would seem like you don't need a whole
lot of special skills to be a success
but Gong bang serves a real purpose
helping people focus or at least that's
what the content creator and the fans
are saying well it might seem
distracting to watch YouTube while doing
your work they say it actually is a
helpful way to avoid distractions it's
on duty all this evening on in support
check on then
tungee will meet up I got super fun and
aramta recommends all catch me a guitar
and then come give another psycho your
channel name though and based on some of
the comments this method seems to be
working I'm an engineering student a
week ago I wasn't motivated at all then
I found your channel thank you for
saving me I feel more concentrated on my
exam preparation Thank You Jaime for
your video it's actually very nice and
helpful really every time there
attempted to do something on their phone
or go somewhere on their website they
kind of look up and see that I'm still
studying on the screen so it kind of
motivates them to keep studying and
while they do make money off the videos
with YouTube ads they say viral fame and
fortune isn't why they're doing it keep
in mind these youtubers are studying for
careers outside of YouTube like tax
accountants and doctors they say they're
only using YouTube as a means to an end
that isn't becoming the next Logan Paul
or jenna Marbles the man sitting next to
me he says he even uses the money that
he earns
to give back to his community charities
and nursing homes you can find him on
his channel interacting with his viewers
giving out gift cards for things like
coffee and books to help study tonight a
wooden camión true so go check on
encourage his timing and a core system
and hey so I saw you take a dance around
Ricky oh good job you know I'm done even
more so Moo Myung turmeric oh I see
someone take it well boom loop dive into
2000 how do we say thank you do booty
but I thought I'm gonna go in and I'm
thinking I'm gonna die don't you know
pushing down his followers will often
stick with him until they complete their
exam and share his channel with friends
youth on coop we may come on and show me
his look pattern honey kiss open wound
up with me that Yahoo AJ show me hop
Calvinism young sir may have gotten
gonna eligible guru Vanessa Cogan and
good one I don't wanna be December 2008
a pool but what happens when the tests
are over for these youtubers what can
their followers expect both Jamie and
the man sitting next to me say they plan
to keep filming themselves but perhaps
with different content related to their
careers thing uh-huh get what you mean
kagu take a little time with you while I
thought kids liked what we all think
it's got a little help okay then yeah
get it on and your cousin
no matter why you watch or when you
watch it all comes down to one thing
making sure you do the work and pass
that test
[Music]
you
[Music]